hi my name is echo Kubik and i'm going
to show you today how to save your time
by automatically extracting the most
important information currently a work
at the Samsung R&D in AI team however
this presentation will be about the new
summarization model that I developed
during my work at the transferee of the
prime minister of Poland the main idea
behind this this model was to provide
the government with the information
about the most important topics in media
on a particle day during this
presentation I will try to explain the
most important steps in the new services
in the new summarization model and I
will try to explain how how they produce
the good output of this in
decimalisation but first of all I would
like to answer why I choose unsupervised
learning for this task when it comes to
supervised learning and natural language
processing we have nowadays a lot of pre
trained models but they are mostly for
English and we have lack of models for
Polish and other languages furthermore
there is lack of training data for other
languages than English and as I said I
was working and at the Chancellery of
the Prime Minister and we didn't have
access to GPUs so we couldn't train our
own models or we didn't have link
linguists to create our own data sets
and last but not least the summarization
problem of news it's complex we have the
multi document problem so we can it
means that we cannot input 300 articles
into single neural network and just have
that summarization the abstractive
summarization so we so the answer is
obvious we need to we need to use a
supervised learning before I will go
deeper into the pipeline of the model I
would like to explain
key key words that I will use during
this presentation first of all when I
use the word when I say token I mean
word it's not always true but for the
purpose of this representation token
means word limit ization
is a process of reducing award trees to
its basic grammar form it is very
important in languages such as polish TF
matrix is a matrix that contains row
kinds of terms in this in this context
tokens or worse occurring in a set of
documents IDF is a measure which down
scales words that appear very frequently
in many documents and imbedding it's a
kind of representation and on numeric
representation of a word and the cosine
similarity is a measure or the
similarity between two vectors where
where value of one means that two
vectors are mostly the same minus one
means that they are negative they have
negative directions and zero means they
have nothing in common so so now the
pipeline before we process the articles
we need to scrape them then we have to
we have the pre-processing of the
articles I need to explain the colors
also because the model was developed in
both Python and R and yellow means
Python and blue means are so scraping
was done with scrappy and pre-processing
with tidy text then we have to identify
the most important words on a particle
day if we have important words we need
also dimensionality reduction as I said
we have 400 articles and this articles
usually has
have ten paragraphs so we have many
dimensions and if we if we have if we
have many many sites we have many many
columns in matrix so we need to reduce
the dimensionality if we have the
important words and also embedding so
the vector representation of words we
may start to class to them into topics
if we have topics so that consistent
groups of words then we may start to
summarize them with the use of legs rank
which I will describe later on and at
the end of the pipeline there is output
with the report I would like to start
from the words importance in 1993 that
Danny proposed to identify big Rams with
the use of log like like a few of them
likelihood ratio test but the same idea
the same approach may be used to
identify whether the word appears more
frequently today then induced that mean
then it used to be during for example
the whole last year and this approach is
good for forwards because it doesn't
have that has the assumption of normal
normal distribution it is the assumption
of binomial distribution of of words so
it's it it assumes that words appear
according to binomial distribution and
this is this function it compares two
parameterization so we compare whether
it is there is only one frequency of
word combining our current day and the
reference period or we have two separate
frequencies one p14 our current day in p
zero for the reference period and that
statistics of log minus two logarithm
lambda
hey square distribution so it can be
used for identifying them similar I did
find the important words the only
modification in this dis measure that I
applied was to scaled by minus 1 words
that appear less frequently than in the
reference period because the statistics
test whether there is a difference
between frequencies and if also the
other we also so we select the words
that has statistics higher than 10 and
we also demand that these important
words are a monk amongst 10 percent of
the most frequent word in a particle day
now I'd like I would like to move into
embeddings and this was done with the
use of singular value decomposition they
come the composition because it's pure
algebra it's very fast and it can be use
without without any training like it's
we in the case of worst back or glove
all this other approach required to
train a neural net and this approach is
is very simple and it's very fast but it
still captures a semantic relationship
between between wars so even if we have
for example towards dog and cat and it
doesn't doesn't appear together in the
same articles but when when they are
when there is cat mentioned there is
there are also words associated with
animals
raising pets and domestic animals and
the same is with we've dog we have dog
we have words about animals
pets and etc so at the end the
embeddings of these two words would be
similar because we read these paragraphs
and articles into lower dimensional
eating clustering I think this is very
important part of this art of this of
this model because summarization is one
thing but we need to identify really
consistent topics and for this for this
task I've chosen to use agglomerated
hierarchical clustering because it's
it's it's approach that that doesn't
require to specify number of clusters at
the start of of the other ISM like it's
in in the case of for example k-means so
as I said it's a glue merit of
hierarchical clustering so we start with
n topics when n is the number of words
then we try to find two most similar
words and the similarity is measured by
the Costco sign between embeddings if we
have these two similar words we group
them into topics and the topic has new
embedding that is a sum of that towards
embeddings and we stop when we have only
one topic so we group them all together
and we decide how much how many class or
how many clusters we have by applying
silhouette algorithm it's this is an
algorithm that tries to to assess the
inner similarity and the outer
similarity and to find clustering in
which objects are the most similar to
each other in two are two are the most
similar to each other inside cluster
the most dissimilar to the closest topic
outside this is an example that I
created for them for the articles from
BBC as I said at the beginning the model
was created mainly for Polish but it can
be applied to other languages in this
case English I I scraped articles from
the last week from BBC and this is the
second most important topic on BBC last
week it's the case it's a legal case
between Ellen mask and Vernon password
Vern password it's a British diver who
helped to rescue 12 boys from from cave
in Thailand last year and Ellen mask
called him a pedagogue and this was the
and this legal case concerned this is
this tweet about about being pedo guy
but this varies by venom mask called the
Verner ask for a better guy so we can
see that we have all these words all
these important words here so we have
mask connected with us worth answer of
connected with cave and also a mask is
connected with tweet and there is also
word pedal I will return to this example
at the end and I will show the summary
the automatic summary found for this for
this topic but before this I would like
to explain the summarization tool
applied in this model as I showed during
on the pipeline of the model the
algorithm applied here it's it's Lex Lex
rank and the Lex rank is based on
Google's fundamental fundamental
algorithms PageRank which was
a breakthrough in 1998 which allowed
Google to be the best search engine at
the at the beginning and PageRank is
used to to rank web websites with the
use of Markov chain
so the ranking the output the output of
the algorithm is the steady state of
Markov chain and the mark of matrix is a
weighted mean of random matrix and
matrix consisted of as links between
between pages the legs rank used the
same approach it also used the Markov
chain and find steady state of the of
the matrix but instead of matrix of
flames
it used matrix of cosine similarity
between sentences and the matrix that is
used to build the cosine similarity
matrix is tf-idf however and generally
lacks rank is very good others if you
want to summarize single document it
will find really good sentences if we
want to summarize the novel but in the
case of multi document sources like like
news we have to filter out only articles
that contains topic words and if we do
so then the IDF part of the of the
matrix would downscale the importance of
the topic words and we don't want to do
so because then the topic words would be
unimportant
and because they appear very frequent
very frequently in our sentences but we
still have a measure of importance as I
said there is a dining measure or the
log-likelihood ratio test so we can so
instead of IDF we can
use this out of the output of this test
furthermore we can also calculate cosine
similarity between particle world and
and topic to include more scaling of the
of the crew frequencies and this skelton
frequency we may use to calculate the
sentence embedding which is which is a
dot product between ten frequency and
words embeddings at the end when we have
ranking we may still scale this scale
this output and upscale sentences that
contains many topic words and downscale
long sentences and last but not least is
sentence selection because we want we
don't want to select duplicated
sentences so we just need to compare
recursively going from the most
important and select for example k most
important not duplicated sentences and
we just compared the cosine similarity
between sentences and as i said this is
an example for this legal ties between
mask and a swerve so we have presented
three sentences and David they contains
the main words like pedo guy tweet and
card so we can understand that this this
topic is about a legal case and we also
know what they mean what the main field
of this of this case obviously what was
what was the main issue if you would
like to
gets deeper into the into the model or
seeing an example of the report or use
the model button by yourself it's
published on github on my repository so
if you would like to take advantage take
advantage on it feel free and download
the repository and and yeah and that's
all thank you very much thank you
any questions
why was the model developed using both
Python and our it's because at the
chancellery we use primary R to use any
scripts so the R is like the main
steering script which evokes script
wrote written in Python so Python is
Python runs in the background so this is
the let's say the company culture and
the Python help to accelerate that is
this model a lot okay next question
so is the model actually on production
yes it's on do you know how it performs
in real life is it's really a value for
your customer yes I think it helps to
identify the topics that are hard in
media because we had a problem at the
Chancellery because we were - we were to
check than the media's to read
newspapers and to come maybe not control
but to to be in touch what is going on
in media what was very important to news
etc and it was very hard to find really
relevant information and to assess
whether it appears more frequently than
it used to be and it's this model after
8 months it's still working at the
Chancellery so I think it's the model
that boosted somehow the the way the
transferee works
anyone do you evaluate somehow this
model because I know that there is
similar model is called text rank and
maybe you compared it with it somehow
yes generally text rank is it's only the
idea and they are very similar to two
lakhs rank but Lex rank you see if
scaled TF matrix and Tex rank use the
similarity between words in sentences so
not exactly the TF matrix or sentence
embeddings but but only overlapping of
words so it was the main idea of Tex
rank but they were published in the same
year and I think they are very similar
the idea is the same okay next question
and I thank you for a speech and as a
question which is follow up on the
previous question
is your client counting how many
important events in Poland are missed by
your algorithm it's not offensive and no
I I think I think not this is not this
is not the Oracle and it's only a tool
that helps to make the work faster so
there are still people who says these
reports and if if there is topic that
needs to be scrutinized it's it's done
by by human not the button by algorithm
okay thank you and one more technical
question cause you mentioned M or ten
bindings and also you mentioned that you
have access to de putte to produce own
embeddings what was your source for word
embeddings no this this this this
embeddings are created every time base
articles on the frequencies in articles
and in paragraphs so I don't use word
Tyvek or globe okay so this is just the
decomposition of the matrix of the TF
matrix composed of where we have in rows
particle words and in columns with
paragraphs and articles okay okay so
maybe maybe you considered using
pre-trained models because there are
some available even by fast X yes but
the idea behind this is that we have the
term frequency matrix and we need to
create embeddings for a particle day so
we cannot use glove or anything that is
general we want to compare this
embeddings for a particular day and we
cannot use also this more complicated
neural networks embeddings because there
are even some analysis that shows that
this for example you're worth two Veck
performs very poor very poor when the
corpus is low it is small and we have
300 articles more or less every day so
we don't have billions of words like it
was used to Train globe okay I don't
mean training but using existing one but
that makes sense not not to use this big
matrix for for such a semi attacks okay
thank you for this presentation do think
algorithms like this can be used can be
scaled and used for integration maybe
for reading text message like and
thinking what's going on in the society
but you guys do you ask about Poland or
general mostly about governments I think
government's doesn't have how to say the
knowledge to use this in the way you you
ask so this is this is not an issue in
when it comes to governments maybe
Secret Service but not the government
okay next question anyone okay thank you
thank you
you